I think at carnegie-mellon we're really
looking at problems that matter to the
world we're looking at climate change
we're looking at health insurance
decisions decision-making among
teenagers about safe sex we're looking
at workplace discrimination and we're
looking at trying to understand these
issues why they happen but also really
about how to change them and I think
that's really unique about our group is
that we're really interested in change
our brand of behavioral economics is
much more mixed it's about 50% economics
and 50% psychology and I think it's not
just that we have economists and we have
psychologists but the psychologists know
a lot of economics and the economists
know a lot of psychology a lot of the
work we do begins with concrete problems
like the Earned Income Tax Credit how to
increase savings our colleagues are
Bhargava just worked with a local bank
to try to encourage their employees to
take up their retirement benefit the
employees weren't taking advantage of
that and they were losing out on a
thousands of dollars sourabh found that
if he offered employees $10 to get on
the site and sign up for this benefit
they did it in droves that's an example
of behavioral economics where thousands
of dollars of benefits can't compete
with a $10 gift certificate that's a
good example of how the details really
matter it's really the the way in which
such incentives and policies are framed
and
communicator and that basic insight has
a potential to radically improve the
ability of policies to lead to better
outcomes there's a tremendous amount of
interaction between people have never
seen a department that's as interactive
as our department I'm around I'm such a
variety of people like experts in
organizational behavior marketing
psychology decision-making and every
week we meet everybody comes there we
share ideas and I haven't seen that in
other places it's such an amazing
experience the feedback from an audience
that is so diverse this is truly amazing
well a lot of our research does use
Carnegie Mellon undergraduates as
research participants it's nice to go
out in the community and get a different
type of population I think we have the
only mobile lab that we can drive into
different neighborhoods which is another
example of the uniqueness of our program
Carnegie Mellon is really one of the few
institutions in the world that has these
intimate relationships with with
government agencies at the local state
and and federal levels through which we
can communicate these these findings and
directly reshape actual policies in a
way that that is measurable and
impactful
you